[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: One
of the hang-ups
of having an awesome, modern,
complex mobile application
is all the stuff you've gotta
do just to get it working
so the user is happy.
It seems counterintuitive
then that when
you do all that stuff
before the app boots up,
it can actually
cause unhappy users.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and
one of the common problems
with slow launch
performance is doing
too much stuff inside of your
application's initialization
code.
Remember that any time
your app launches,
the system will display
a startup window
until everything is up, ready,
and your app has been drawn.
The longer the users are staring
at this window the less happy
they generally get
with your application.
Now, a common seen-all-the-time
problem that can cause this is
spending too much time
in processing cycles
in the initialization of
custom application objects.
Now, while it's really important
to do some types of global work
here, remember that the rest
of the application launching
process can't move forward
until this initialization is
finished.
And don't get me
wrong, sometimes this
isn't intentional.
I mean, it's not like
you're going out of your way
to put lots of work
in this object.
The application subclasses
tend to become repositories
for the full set
of potential things
an app may need
to be initialized
for all the possible
activities in your app.
The result is a lot of wasted
work in the most common cases.
Now, particularly
difficult in these
situations is when
you get things
like blocking code, garbage
collection events, disk
I/O, or lots of network pings.
You know, all the
heavy work that's
sitting right in the middle
of the most critical step
of your initialization.
Now, before you run into
the weeds here trying
to address these
issues, it's worth
figuring out if
you have a problem.
Thankfully, Android
has some tools to help.
First is the method
profiling tool,
which lets you graphically
see how long your application
on Create method is taking.
If it's going longer than
four to 10 milliseconds then
it's worth exploring
more to see what
might be causing that delay.
And to get that information,
you can drill down
by adding tracing functions
to your code, which will then
show up in the next
Systrace capture
that you run for
your application.
And let's be clear.
The solution to all
of these problems
is simple-- lazy loading.
See, while you can
initialization subclasses
and systems for all
activities your app will need,
doing all this stuff up front
is just complete overkill.
So only a subset of
these items are actually
critical for the main activity.
And thus, those are the only
ones that should be worked on.
The rest should be deferred
to some later time.
Basically, this
boils down to moving
things out of the critical
path of the application
initialization and either
doing that work on demand,
like a subclass for a
particular activity,
or doing that work
in the background,
allowing the results to be
returned asynchronously.
See, performance is all
about user perception.
And the critical path
of launching your app
is where users can
perceive slowdown the most.
So to figure out how to
fix up the other parts
of your application, make
sure you watch the rest
of our Android Performance
Patterns videos on YouTube,
and don't forget to join the
Google+ community to chat with
other brilliant
performance folks.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.